- Welcome to the Lifespan podcast
where we discuss the science of aging
and how to be healthier
at any stage of life.
I'm David Sinclair,
I'm a professor of genetics
at Harvard Medical School
and I'm co-director of
the Paul F. Glenn Center
for Biology of Aging Research.
This podcast series is about why we age
and why we may not have to.
Things you can do today and going forward
to increase your wellness
and to potentially live a
much longer healthier life.
We've talked about the biology of aging,
we've talked about things
that you can do at home,
preferably under the
supervision of your doctor,
and today, we're going
to talk about things
that you definitely will be talking to
and requiring a doctor's
supervision to do,
and even things that your
doctor is unable to do,
but potentially in the
future may be able to.
I'm joined today by my
co-host and my co-author,
the lovely Matthew LaPlante.
Hey Matt.
- Hey.
We're back.
We're doing it again.
- We are definitely doing it.
Today, we're doing a deep dive into some,
you know, somewhat controversial stuff.
- This is a scary episode.
- Well, I don't know if it's scary,
but we have to do a disclaimer, I think.
We have to say that what we're
going to talk about today,
a lot of it isn't approved by the FDA,
but maybe in the future,
and some things that were
available until recently,
and were banned by the FDA,
and currently available only off shore.
- And just as was the case
when we had the conversation
about drugs and supplements,
and maybe even more so in this case,
there's a lot of misinformation out there
about a lot of things
that we're going to be
talking about today,
these potential avenues
for addressing longevity.
We're going to try to cut through that,
but we are not doctors
of the physician type.
- That's right.
I'm a PhD in genetics,
I'm not a physician.
And so the things we've
talked about in this series
should always be done with the supervision
and advice from your physician.
- Yeah, a podcast is no
substitute for a physician.
- That's right.
But I'm a scientist, I can
read the scientific literature,
can distill that down, you're
a science communicator,
and we're here to be able to distill
the wealth of information
that's out there and distinguish
what's fact from fiction and give people
a starting point as to
really, how do they figure out
what's best for their wellness
and what's actual complete bull out there.
- And so today we're
going to be talking about
stem cell therapy, peptides,
exosomes, testosterone,
growth hormone, and then
we're going to spend
a little time talking about
one of your favorite subjects,
epigenetic reprogramming,
but we can't do that
until we do something else first.
- Well, we need to thank the sponsors
who make this podcast freely available.
Our first sponsor is Athletic Greens,
the all-in-one daily drink
to support better health
and peak performance.
Athletic Greens is a greens powder
developed from a complex blend
of 75 vitamins, minerals,
and whole foods sourced ingredients.
It's filled with adaptogens for recovery,
probiotics, and digestive
enzymes for gut health.
There's also vitamin C and zinc
citrate for immune support.
I've been drinking Athletic Greens
every morning for a few years.
I really like it because I travel a lot,
and I don't often eat perfectly,
and I can rest assured by
drinking Athletic Greens
I'm getting everything I need
for optimal wellness and health.
So if you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair
to claim a special offer.
They giving five free travel packs
plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 for immune health
and vitamin K2, which keeps the
calcium out of your arteries
and puts it into your
bones where it's needed.
Again, go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair
to claim this special offer.
Today's podcast is also brought
to us by Inside Tracker.
Inside Tracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and DNA
to help you better understand your body
and reach your health goals.
I like Inside Tracker
because they present the data
in a really clear form,
and the nutritional advice
is really actionable and has
been shown scientifically
to improve many blood biomarkers.
And if you're not looking at
what's going on in your body,
you have no idea whether what you're doing
is actually working or not working.
Another feature that Inside Tracker has
is their inner age test.
This test shows you what
your biological age is,
and you can optimize that.
They also make the tests
really easy to take.
You can have people come to your house
to have your blood drawn, or
you can go to a local clinic.
So if you'd like to try Inside Tracker,
you can visit inside tracker.com/sinclair,
and you'll get 25% of
any Inside Tracker plan.
Use the code Sinclair at the checkout.
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by Levels.
Levels is an app that syncs
with a continuous glucose
monitor that they provide
and interprets your glucose data for you.
I've been so impressed by Levels
that I recently joined them as an advisor.
By monitoring your blood glucose,
Levels allows you to see how
different foods impact you.
I've been really successful at impacting
my blood glucose levels positively.
I found that foods like
grapes spike my glucose
and potatoes don't do so much,
so that's really important,
because I don't get those highs
anymore followed by a crash
which leads to a brain fog and lethargy.
So if you'd like to try Levels,
you can skip the 150,000 person wait list
and joined today by going
to levels.link/sinclair.
That's levels.link/sinclair.
- All right, let's dive
in by starting today
with testosterone.
Super popular subject.
Lots and lots of growth in
testosterone replacement
right now, because of the
fact that testosterone
decreases as we age,
and that's disconcerting
to a lot of people.
- Oh, for sure.
After the age of 30 to 40, we lose about
1% of our testosterone
levels, men and women,
it's important for both sexes.
But the market has grown.
So TRT or testosterone replacement therapy
has grown from a few
hundred million 10 years ago
to multi-billion dollars now.
And it's widely used
not just to supplement
for sexual dysfunction,
which is a common side
effect of low testosterone,
but for other things that
include mental health,
building muscle, overall
fitness, vitality.
- And people swear by this.
I mean, a lot of people did, they do this,
they say they feel younger,
they say they feel more vigorous.
They want to have sex again.
They want to have sex all the time.
There's an important
distinction to make here though,
which is just because you feel younger,
does not necessarily mean
you are reversing your biological aging.
- Right.
Let's make a clear distinction.
We've talked about adversity mimetics
and the last episode, we
talked about the supplements
and the kind of things that
you can do in your life
to mimic that.
We want our bodies to
be in a state of fear.
That times are tough,
and they need to hunker down and survive.
There are other types of things
that we're going to talk about,
which are abundance mimetics.
Testosterone is one,
we're going to get to
growth hormone as well.
These tell the body that times a good,
to build your muscle, to
reproduce, go forth, multiply.
- And that's what testosterone is doing.
We get testosterone replacement therapy,
we are putting a substance
back into our body
that has been reduced,
but which signals our body
that times are good enough,
it's okay to build muscle,
it's okay to run around
chasing wooly mammoths,
chasing the cave women around.
- Yes.
That for sure.
And that benefited our
ancestors very well,
but it didn't help them long-term.
What we now are appreciate
is the body has cycles
of want and need and adversity,
which is good for the
long-term health of the body,
and times where things are
abundant, times to grow,
reproduce, which are great short-term,
but probably not great
for long-term health
and longevity either.
- Okay, so let's talk
about what actually happens
when our testosterone lowers
and what happens importantly
when we put it back.
Because this is helping a lot of people
with a lot of problems that
are coincidal with aging.
- Oh, for sure.
There've been a lot of
studies, millions of dollars,
and many thousands of
people treated with TRT
as it's called.
Shelly Basin, who's a
colleague of mine at Harvard
has done a lot of these studies,
and he's found some improvements,
short term improvements,
so of course improvements in libido,
but also he shows a
dose dependent increase
in skeletal muscle mass,
so you get bigger muscles,
you got more power, you can climb stairs,
you can walk further in six minutes,
improves aerobic capacity.
These are all good things that he sees,
but actually it's not all good news.
There were some side effects
and may actually impact longevity.
So some of the risks of TRT,
there's worst sleep apnea,
you can actually get larger breasts.
A little lower fact is your testosterone
can be turned into estrogen,
which is a risk for men particularly.
You can have what's called
benign prostatic hyperplasia.
So bigger prostate, need to
go to the bathroom at night,
shrinking testicles, not something I think
many of us would want,
and increasing red blood cell protection,
which could lead to blood clots.
- And if you're already
predisposed to prostate cancer,
you have cancerous growth already.
This could actually aggravate the tumors.
- Yes.
And actually the opposite is true for you.
If you look at the history
of eunuchs, they live longer.
And so it may actually
be that supplementing
with testosterone is not
conducive to longer life.
- So this is an important principle here,
and we're going to come back
to this a couple of times
on this episode, which is just because
something makes you feel good today,
and just because it might
even be medically beneficial
to you today, that does
not necessarily mean
it is addressing the
causes of biological aging.
It maybe fixing something
that you have a problem with,
it may be improving even your quality
of life right now long-term,
that's not the same thing
as reducing or eliminating biological age.
- Yeah, let's go back to
the main concept here today,
which is that adversity
mimetics are great,
things that mimic lack of
food and a lot of exercise,
but these abundance mimetics
are probably a problem long-term
even though they make you
feel great short term.
- Okay.
And that's sort of giving
away the punchline for HGH,
but we need to talk about HGH as well.
Human growth hormone, also something
that is really popular right now,
people supplementing
with human growth hormone
to address things like
decreased exercise capacity,
decreased bone density,
decreased muscle mass,
and increased body fat.
This works, right, for those things.
HGH is helpful.
- Well, no question.
Short-term, you'll feel
better, you'll grow muscle,
you'll have less fat on
growth hormone therapy.
The science says that this may not be good
for long-term health and wellness.
Going back to the original
studies of Cynthia Kenyon,
which we talked about in episode one,
those mutant worms had low
levels of growth hormone
and insulin like growth hormone signaling.
- And they live longer.
- Twice as long.
And this has been reproduced also in mice.
And even in humans, there
are the Loren dwarfs,
we were talking about earlier.
These are smaller people
that have low levels
of growth hormone, or actually IGF-1,
one of the versions of this pathway,
they are relatively
resistant against cancer
and heart disease, and
may even live longer.
Conversely, if you're supplementing
with growth hormone long-term,
the chances that you're
having the opposite.
That you feel great, but long-term,
you might have even greater risk of cancer
and heart disease.
- And you know people who are
on HGH for various reasons.
One of the immediate side effects,
even before we get to the sort of like
the longevity implications is sore joints,
carpal tunnel syndrome.
- Right.
This is the kind of thing
that that does happen.
Now, I just want to be clear.
There are some benefits
to bringing the levels
back up to normal, okay?
But going to high,
which a lot of people do
if they want additional benefits,
that's where I think that
the main risk comes from.
- Another risk immediate is
increased insulin resistance.
- That's true.
We get high levels of blood sugar
or we get high cholesterol,
carpal tunnel, edema,
so buildup of fluid, joint pain.
- Okay, so soreness in your
joints, insulin resistance,
another one is an
increase in the likelihood
of type two diabetes because
of that insulin resistance.
All of this actually kind of
sounds like symptoms of aging.
- Right.
And that's the risk, that the
animal studies are telling us
that growth hormone will tell
your body that times are good,
abundance mimetic, and that's not good
for long-term effects of health,
and probably what's going on
is some acceleration of aging.
- Okay, this isn't to say
again, I think this really,
we don't want to say human
growth hormone is bad.
Testosterone is bad.
People need to have a
naturally healthy level
of these hormones in their bodies.
- There are ways to do that naturally.
So with testosterone, you can
work out the bigger muscles
in your body and that also
help with growth hormone.
So I work out my thighs
and my back particularly,
keep those nice and strong,
and I've found my natural
testosterone levels
go up to normal levels with that.
So that's the way to do it.
With growth hormone, it's all about eating
at the right time and sleeping.
So if you eat not too close to sleep time,
and then you rest through the night,
and have a good night's sleep,
that's the best way to improve
your growth hormone levels.
- And if you're doing all of that
and you're still struggling
to keep these levels up,
that's the time to talk to your doctor
about supplementation,
but that supplementation needs to be aimed
not at a hyper increasing
the levels of these
in your bodies, but just keeping them
at that sort of like that
natural healthy level.
- Well, exactly.
But I would encourage everyone
to try it naturally first
- So so far, this sort
of feels like bad news,
'cause these are the
things that a lot of people
have gotten into their heads
that might be beneficial to anti-aging,
and what you're saying and
what the evidence suggests
is that there is no anti-aging benefit,
there might be a short term gain,
not a long-term anti-aging benefit,
but these aren't the only things
that are sort of like hot
on the market right now.
Another thing that's really
popular to talk about,
really popular to try, where it is legal,
is peptide supplementation.
- Yeah.
So peptides, just like
hormones, are made of
strings of amino acids,
but typically smaller.
About a hundred amino acids.
You can synthesize them on a machine
or extract them from tissues,
and they're used by cells to
communicate between each other.
So your brain will put out
peptides to signal the body,
your liver, and your muscle,
and some of these are really good.
Some are really bad.
We don't know what they all do.
There are probably a
thousand made by the body.
We've probably only know
about what 20 of them do
in great detail.
- What we do know is, as a class,
they help cells
communicate to one another.
- Right.
- And so just sort of like
holistically speaking,
it's like, oh, that's really good,
because in part aging is a
loss of cellular communication,
and so peptides help increase
that cellular communication.
Voila, they must be great for aging.
- Well, again, it's whether
you're in adversity mimetic,
or an abundance mimetic.
That's the difference.
And really you have to make a distinction
between those two things.
One of the best studied
peptides of all time is insulin,
and clearly that's important
if you're deficient in it.
We've known this since the 1920s.
- We actually have a hundred
years now, it was in 1921,
which was when insulin
was first discovered.
- Right.
Banting and Best was 1921,
found they could extract
this insulin extract from
the pancreas of a dog
and injected into a dog that had diabetes
and cure it within hours.
- And within months, they were
trying this on human beings,
because that's how
things worked back then.
- Yeah, and they even
won Nobel Prizes quicker.
It was only one or two years afterwards
that they won the Nobel prize for that.
- So they went from this works in dogs
to let's try this out in a 14 year old boy
to Nobel prize in the
span of like two years.
- Well, it was worth it,
because in those days,
particularly type one diabetics,
which is the childhood version of this,
the lack of insulin meant
that they would have to go,
the kids would have to
go on a starvation diet
and even then, they would
die within a year or so.
It was horrific.
And suddenly people
were living for decades.
That first patient lived
for another 13 years.
- And so this set us down
the road of studying peptides
and their health benefits,
and then a really big thing
happened in the sixties,
which is we figured out
how to synthesize peptides.
- Right.
That was a big deal.
And then in 1978, they started to be made
using recombinant DNA technology.
And that's where we find
ourselves today is that
most of these hormones and peptides
that are available on the market
are made using recombinant DNA technology.
Though these very small
peptides are unique
because you can synthesize
them on machine,
which makes them very cheap.
- Didn't you say like some people
have these machines at their homes?
- Yeah, I'm aware of some
people that have them
and they're making them at
home and injecting themselves.
I don't recommend that.
That's currently, that's
off label use of drugs
and you don't want to do that,
but that gives you an idea
how it possible it is to
make a drug these days,
especially these peptides.
- Because there are at this
point, so easy to synthesize,
and because they're relatively cheap,
and because they are relatively non-toxic,
there's been lots and
lots of clinical studies
on the use of peptides.
- Right.
Thousands of human studies.
And it's interesting.
Why are they so safe?
Well, they're not foreign.
They're typically already
found in the body,
and they're small, so
they don't typically have
an immune reaction, though
the risk is not zero.
- They're metabolized quickly.
- They're also metabolized quickly.
And so that the risk is relatively low,
and for that reason, there
are a number of doctors
who have been okay giving
these peptides to patients.
- And what we're looking for
when we give peptides to people,
specifically for the cause of anti-aging,
is a boost of regenerative signaling.
- Right.
So what you're looking for is the ability
to recover from damage,
increased wound healing,
lower blood sugar levels,
increased mitochondrial activity.
Those are examples or signatures
of an adversity mimetic,
not an abundance mimetic.
- Okay, let's talk about some of these
we have discussed in the past, MOTS-C.
- Right.
- MOTS-C.
So M-O-T-S dash C.
That's a really interesting peptide,
an unusual class that
actually doesn't come
from the nucleus, that normal chromosomes
that we talk about,
but from the mitochondrial
DNA in mitochondria,
and up until about 10 years ago,
we thought that there were only 13 genes
encoded in the mitochondrial genome,
and there are now about a hundred known
and MOTS-C is probably the
best characterized of those.
There's another one
called humanin as well.
MOTS-C, when injected into mice,
lowers blood sugar levels,
increases mitochondrial activity,
gives you the signatures of long life,
probably promotes life,
there's some evidence of that,
and has been in humans.
In fact, there's a clinical
trial that was just released,
the results of which showed
that it reduces fat in the body
and improves fatty liver, which are again,
signatures of potential longevity.
- And so your belief at this point is that
there are likely peptides
that are valuable
when it comes to addressing
the causes of biological aging,
unlike these other things
we've talked about today.
- Well, almost certainly,
but we don't know enough
yet to say for sure
that these are perfectly safe
or we'll increase lifespan,
they lot less is known
about these peptides
than testosterone or growth hormone.
- And to that end, the FDA agrees.
They're nervous.
- Well yeah, because
they became so popular,
typically on the west coast, LA,
there was a real megatrend
and still is to try these out.
And they have variety of properties
that seem to be beneficial anecdotally.
Improving memory, muscle
mass, lowering inflammation.
The FDA looked at this
and said, "whoa, hold on.
We don't know enough."
And they sent a letter
to a company saying,
"stop making this."
And then that sent shock waves.
This was March of 2020.
And so since then, it's been impossible
to get some of these peptides
in the United States.
- Because they've
stopped compounding them.
- Right.
So even though there have
been some promising results
with peptides, the FDA
has said some of these
need to be regulated, and many of them now
you cannot get in the United States.
- So they're still in clinical studies,
researchers are still examining them,
but the avenues for getting
these in the United States
have become more limited,
there are still people
getting them overseas,
compounding them in their
own machines at home.
- Right.
But still we have to be careful,
because they're not all perfectly safe.
And one of the reasons the
FDA was nervous about this
and banned many of them is that
there are some side effects.
It's not just that they can be redness
where they're injected,
but actually it seems
like you can induce arthritis type effects
when the immune system recognizes
these peptides as foreign.
And that would be something
you definitely wouldn't want to have
is an immunological reaction.
- A lot of these have names,
they're like star wars droids.
And so people have heard
these, heard of these,
they might wonder what they're doing.
One that's really popular
in conversation right now
is BP-157.
- Yeah, BP-157 is one of
the more popular ones.
It's been used to increase
blood flow, lower inflammation,
and even regenerate neurons
for cognitive ability.
But there are lots of others.
There's one called SS-31
which targets the mitochondria
and improves mitochondrial function,
could seem to be good for the
heart, maybe for longevity.
There's another popular
one called GHK-Copper,
it's part of a copper complex,
was first identified in human plasma.
later, is found in saliva and urine.
And it's been used to help wound healing,
attract immune cells,
and it's an anti-oxidant,
stimulates collagen, protects
tissues against inflammation,
can even be used apparently
to reduce fine lines,
wrinkles, and grow hair again.
There's a whole bunch of-
- Is this based on, I mean,
is this anecdotal evidence?
Is this research-based evidence?
How do we know these things
about these different peptides?
- Yeah, most of these
come from mouse studies
and then they're anecdotal from studies
that clinicians are currently doing.
But yeah, again, I want to stress
that most of these things that
we're saying are anecdotal
and not yet scientifically validated.
- These are some people's experiences
and this is all one of the reasons
why there is a pretty
significant movement right now,
this sort of like save
peptides movement of people
who are contacting the FDA and saying,
"please make these things
more available to us again."
- Well, yeah, there's one in particular,
thymus and alpha one, which has been known
since the 1970s to be
beneficial, it seems to be great,
particularly for helping against
fighting bacteria and viral infections,
but it was also listed on the
banned substances in 2020,
and there's a movement to bring it back,
because with COVID-19, it's
thought that it could help.
Talking about other ones,
some of these work with
fat loss apparently.
We've got to some Tesamorelin CJC-1295
is taken with one called
Ipamorelin, there's AOD-9604,
and the BP-157 again,
can be good for weight loss apparently.
One of the other ones I mentioned humanin
is, again, one of those
mitochondrial derived peptides
like MOTS-C, and in mice at least,
has been shown to help
against type two diabetes,
high blood sugar, cardiovascular disease,
and even help with
neurodegenerative disease
like Alzheimer's.
But in humans, it's not
clear if that's true.
Pinealon is a really interesting one.
It's actually an active peptide complex
and has been thought to treat
memory, attention deficits,
brain injury, stroke,
chronic fatigue, et cetera.
But again, early days.
We don't know for sure if this
is actually true in humans.
And then finally, oh,
we should just mention,
there are others that are
used to combat fatigue
and also boost the immune system.
They go by names like Dixhexa,
Cerebrolysin, Semax, Selank,
or even BPC 157 is used with some Semax,
and Cerebrolysin together.
Again, these are all
pretty much experimental.
They've been shown to
be effective in mice,
but still we have a long way to go
before we know if they're
truly effective in humans.
And there, we always
need placebo controlled,
double blind clinical studies.
- Which are underway.
I mean, there's lots and lots
of clinical studies going on.
It's just not moving as fast as I think
a lot of people would
really like it to move.
But that's the reality of the
space that we're in right now.
- Well, it is, and often it is frustrating
and I can speak from personal
experience how long it takes
to make a drug can be extremely slow,
and we're all getting
older, we're not getting,
in the case of most of us,
we're not getting any younger,
and there is a desire to rush into things,
but I think we need to
exercise some caution here,
because you can have these
negative side effects,
particularly in the case of
peptides, an immune reaction
they could be deleterious in the long run.
- And in that long run
though, you see these
as a very promising avenue
for a lot of therapies
that are going to help a lot of people.
Not just with individual conditions,
but you think with aging.
- Oh, for sure.
Not all of these, of course,
but those that mimic adversity.
MOTS-C is a good example of one
that I think has the right signature.
I think they have a lot of promise.
- Because there is an
explosion of research
going on sort of at the
same time with peptides
and this other thing that
we're about to talk about,
exosomes, I think these
happened in the same breath.
A lot of times people talk
about peptides and exosomes.
Both of these are cellular signalers,
but exosomes work, well,
they are different,
and they work a little differently.
- Well, very different.
These are packages of information.
They contain, well,
they're membrane bound,
so they're little vesicles,
they're about the size of a virus,
so they travel between cells
and into cells very easily,
and inside, it's not just one message.
There's multiple messages.
There's peptides inside,
there's DNA, there's RNA,
even what are called micro RNAs,
which are similar to
peptides, very small pieces,
in this case of nucleic acid material,
that can go from the
brain to other tissues
from tissues back up to the brain.
And this is essentially the
way the body can coordinate.
So if there's an injury on your
hand, your brain will know,
or if your brain gets injured,
the rest of your body knows,
and you need to have these messengers
to coordinate the system in the same way
you could imagine the US post.
And so these a little
mail deliveries of cargoes
that we can both intercept and read,
perhaps we can use these
to diagnose diseases,
including cancer, but also
we can make more of them
and infuse them into people
to give a false alarm,
perhaps even, to simulate this adversity
and make us live longer.
- And before we get to
those therapeutic processes,
one of the really fast moving avenues
for using exosomes is
basically collecting them
from the blood, counting them up,
and being able to diagnose
different injuries.
And even like, you can pull
people's blood these exosomes,
and then you can say like,
"oh, they have an injury here.
They have a disease there."
- Right.
Yeah, there are companies now that,
there's one called Zar
Therapeutics, there are others,
that you can read the cargo,
and you can say, "okay, that
comes from the pancreas.
That is a signature of a stage
three pancreatic cancer."
So we may be able to use these
to diagnose cancer years in advance.
- Without biopsying-
- Right, just a blood test or
even a finger prick at home,
send it off, and diagnose cancer.
- And that would be reason
enough to be excited, I think,
about the potential for exosomes
to tell us what's going on in our bodies,
but what else we're learning
right now about exosomes
is that if we supplement
these into the bodies of mice,
like by injecting them into their,
back in to their bloodstreams,
it can help with injury.
- Yeah.
I mean, there's a really
well-known paper now
from August 2017, by my good colleague
down at Albert Einstein
College of Medicine,
Dong Shanghai, and his
expertise is looking
how the hypothalamus, the little organ
at the base of the brain communicates
to the rest of the body,
and he's found that
inflammation in and damage
to that part of the body
affects the rest of the animal,
including aging.
And in this case, he found, interestingly,
that neuronal stem cells,
these progenitors in the hypothalamus,
they secrete exosomes that tell the body
to hunker down and survive.
And the mouse can actually live longer
if you isolate these exosomes
and give it to the mouse.
They also did the opposite,
they deleted these special cells
that make the exosomes and
the mice got diseases of aging
and lived shorter.
- Why is it happening?
- Well, we don't know.
In most cases, there's so many things
within the exosomes that we,
it's very hard to figure out
which of those particular cargoes
is responsible for the biological effect,
but ultimately if we can figure that out,
we could make exorcisms with
just that particular component,
and that could be a drug in the future.
- There was another fairly
recent paper on exosomes,
2019 paper from some Chinese researchers
that used exosome replacement
to address ulcer healing,
and what they concluded
was that the exosomes
are actually rejuvenating senescent cells.
Really fascinating here.
- Well that, so senescent cells,
if you miss the previous
episode, our cells,
that as they get old and
they have ex-differentiation,
they lose their ability to
read this their DNA correctly.
They become senescent.
They stopped dividing.
They sit there, and they start secreting
inflammatory molecules, can
even cause cancer to develop.
We try to delete these cells.
We know that in a mouse
and probably in a human,
if you get rid of these
inflammatory senescent cells,
it's good for health.
But here we're saying, what
the researchers are saying,
is that these exosomes,
a particular type of exosomes
can reverse senescence.
That's unheard of.
If that turns out to be true,
that would be quite a remarkable thing,
meaning one day we don't
have to kill off these cells,
which in the brain,
you wouldn't want to do that necessarily,
we could actually rejuvenate them,
and get them to grow again, healthily.
- Right now, the way we
understand how to do that
is through the Yamanaka factors,
but this would be another avenue
toward that same goal of
taking exdifferentiated cells
and sending them back into
a differentiated state.
- Well, the Yamanaka factor,
rejuvenation of senescent
cells is preliminary.
This is some of the work
we're doing in my lab,
and it's not even clear
if the Yamanaka factors
are pertinent enough
to reverse senescence,
but this finding that you referred to
is the first instance at
that that might be possible.
- All of this is why
there's a lot of excitement
around this particular potential therapy.
But again, just like peptides,
this is sort of the wild west right now,
but people are already taking exosomes
and having them shot into their bodies.
- They can be delivered
by IV or intramuscularly,
but again, we, we don't know
what the longterm benefits
or side effect are.
So we have to be careful.
It's still available in
some parts of the US,
but we don't know.
- This is not one of those things
you have to go to Costa Rica
for, at least as of right now,
the FDA hasn't cracked down,
they haven't said this is a step too far.
- That's right.
But while exosomes
aren't completely banned
in the United States,
you can bet that the FDA
is looking at this for a
potential safety concerns.
And we'll see how things
go over the next few years.
- That's not the same thing as
saying, like, "go do it now!"
- No, no, that's not what we're here for.
oWe want to educate and look
at what might be available
down the line once things are proven
to be safe and effective.
- And this is another one of
those things, like peptides,
you're feeling positive
that there is going to be
actual clinical research that will show us
the actual benefits of these.
We don't have to make
super, super guesses,
we can actually see in the research
how exosomes are going to be beneficial
and then start to implement
them into our longevity regimes
in a responsible way.
- That's right.
And just to be clear, exosomes are
a highly validated scientific pursuit,
and there are biotech companies,
pharmaceutical companies,
building giant factories,
billions of dollars,
to make exosomes, to treat diseases.
The question is, do they
work for long-term health
and longevity and how safe they are
to be used over decades.
That we don't know yet.
- Okay, let's move than
into an area of research
that is even further along.
Still, we're learning more
about every single day,
but also has potential
anti-aging implications.
Stem cells.
Let's start with a little primer.
Stem cells are?
- Stem cells are cells that
can divide asymmetrically
to produce cells that
go on to make tissues.
So for skin, you need stem cells to make
all the skin that grows
over your lifetime,
and they retain youth so
that they can keep dividing
over and over, and they don't become
any particular certain
cell type over time.
- And stem cells can
become more stem cells
or they can become any kind of cell.
- And there's a few different types.
- Right.
- The two main classes are multipotent,
which can make a few
different types of tissues,
these are cells that you
typically get from an embryo.
We can go all the way back to age zero,
and what are called
pluripotent stem cells,
which can make any type of
cell in any type of tissues.
- And you can think of this sort of like
as one of those trees, right?
Like you have the pluripotent
cell that can do anything,
and then after a while,
a little further down in the development,
you have the multipotent cells,
which are still able to transition
into several different kinds of cells,
but not all the different kinds of cells.
- Exactly.
And so if you want to
build a mini human brain
or rebuild a kidney out of a skin cell,
you have to wind the clock
all the way back to zero
and start again, and that's called
inducing a pluripotent stem cell state.
- And that goes back to what
we were talking about earlier,
the Yamanaka factors,
this is one of the ways
that we've identified that
we can turn a stem cell
or any kind of cell from being a stem cell
back into a state of pluripotency.
- Yeah, let's just talk
about Shinya Yamanaka,
because it's really
quite an amazing story.
So Yamanaka in Japan,
in the early well, 2010s
was, in his lab, was figuring
out or trying to figure out
how do you take an adult cell
from an animal or a human
and make it pluripotent.
'Cause if you could do that,
imagine you could build
any tissue you wanted,
and he was trying lots of
different gene combinations
and hit upon five genes
that when put together,
worked to take, so I could
take your skin cell now
using Yamanaka genes or Yamanaka factors
and make a pluripotent stem
cell line and rebuild you.
I could even turn you, by the
way into a sperm and an egg,
and clone you, but I won't do that.
So Yamanaka found the following genes.
So KLF4, SOX2, c-MYC, and LIN28.
We use three of them
particularly in my lab,
we'll talk about that later,
O, S, and K for short,
but this was a major breakthrough,
because finally you could
take anybody's skin cell,
which you could easily get
from the cheek or a biopsy,
grow that in a dish, reprogram them,
which takes about a week
once you put these genes in,
and when they grow up into
what we call a colony,
which is an assemblage
of about a hundred cells,
you pick those, and now you could grow
basically anything you
want from plant cells.
- Well, and I've seen this in your lab
where you've taken cells from a mouse,
you've induced them into
a state of pluripotency,
and then you have trained them,
for lack of a better word,
to grow into brain cells.
And now you have these little
clusters of brain cells
that look like little brains.
- Well, we've done that for mice,
and we've done that for human.
We have many human brains,
and we take these from old individuals,
old normal individuals, and also patients
that have susceptibility
to Alzheimer's disease.
And again, I think we're going
to talk about this later,
but we have the ability in my
lab to drive aging forwards
in those what are called
cerebral organoids
and even in reverse.
And that's what's important really
for being able to study the human brain
without having to touch patients.
And we can go a lot quicker that way.
- Before we sort of go
down that rabbit hole,
can I take us back just a couple of steps
to how this actually happens?
Like how do you take these
factors and put them into a cell?
- Well, it's actually really easy.
Any high school student could do it.
There are a number of ways.
The old ways of doing it
are you can pass electricity
through the cells in the
dish and they take up DNA
that encodes these Yamanaka genes.
You can put them in what are
called liposomes or liposomes,
which are fat membrane bound little balls,
but the way we do it in the lab,
which is the most efficient,
is we use viruses,
domesticated viruses, that
are typically used in patients
for gene therapy, we use them in the lab,
they called adeno-associated
viruses, or AAVs,
we package inside those
the Yamanaka genes,
and just throw them into the dish,
and they infect all the cells in the dish,
and now those cells are
transgenic, they carry these genes,
and we can turn those
genes on and off at will
using drugs and see what happens.
- And the implication
here is that we can take
these now pluripotent cells,
and then we can use them
to treat areas of the body where the cells
just aren't acting the way
that they're supposed to act anymore.
But there's still a problem
with pluripotent cells, right?
Or sorry, induced
pluripotent cells right now,
and that is cancer.
- Yeah, if you take the
age of a cell back to zero
and allow it to just grow and
if you put it into a mouse
and probably a human, you'll get cancer.
Teratoma's particularly
pernicious type of cancer,
which can be, you know,
a hairy ball of mass,
sometimes with teeth in it.
You don't want that.
So you have to be very careful not to put
these pluripotent stem
cells back into the body
and just let them grow.
- Which is why right now,
most stem cell therapies
aren't using induced
pluripotent stem cells,
they're using harvested stem cells,
and we can get those
from a variety of places.
- Right.
Mainly what we're using, or
what scientists and doctors
are using are what are
called autologous stem cells,
so cells that you take out of your body
from various parts of the body,
typically fat cells on
your back or your hips,
and then purifying them
out, freezing them down
and or putting them back into the body
in different places or
into the bloodstream.
- So we can just suck
stem cells out of fat,
out of adipose tissue.
A lot of people think like,
well, why would we even
go through the process
of trying to induce pluripotency
if we can just take stem cells out of fat?
But one of the things that
I think needs to be said,
and you've done some research on this,
is that stem cells age also.
- They do.
They undergo epigenetic
changes that make them
less able to regenerate new tissues.
And that's also true.
You see that with gray hair and hair loss.
That's the loss of the stem
cells in the hair follicle.
One other thing that
just happened recently,
was discovered that you don't just have
stem cells getting old,
they can even be kicked out
of what's called the
niche, where they belong,
they like to reside, and
that's true for the hair cell.
There's a fascinating video
that I threw up on Twitter
and the stem cell, you could see,
they captured it under the microscope,
which got kicked out.
Anyway, suffice to say,
what is really going on
is that the stem cells
need to be a slowed down
in their aging process or even replaced,
and we're only just
learning how to do that.
- The other thing that
we can do is capture them
at a much younger state.
That's where cord blood comes in.
- Right, and you can
even do that for adults.
The idea is that if
you capture these cells
when they're very young,
or if you're in your
twenties and thirties,
you can bank them, put them in a freezer
for later use either to replace the blood
if you have leukemia, or
even using new technologies
to modify them and grow new tissues,
perhaps even replacing old
blood when we get very old.
- A lot of people that are doing this now,
it's becoming more and more
common for people to say,
"hey, look, I want to
preserve my child's ability
to use those stem cells later on,
even if we're not exactly sure
how they're going to be used,
and so they're banking them.
Your kids are, in their
teens and early adult years,
but if you could go back
in time, would you do this?
- Yeah, we didn't do
that because at the time
it wasn't clear if they would be useful,
but now it's very clear that
there are uses for them,
especially if they get childhood cancer.
And so I would do that.
If I was a new parent, I
would aim to bank those.
How about you?
- Yeah. I mean, so as you know,
I haven't followed you down
every longevity rabbit hole
that you've gone down and the
other people have gone down,
but this is definitely 100% something
that if my child had been born
today, I would absolutely do.
I would be banking their cord blood.
- Yeah.
- If I did want to do that now, though,
how would I go about doing that?
- Well, there are
companies you can contact
and often the hospital and
the doctors you work with
know how to do this, but
you need to get ready,
you at least need a few days, often a week
to get ready for this, because
you need to spin them down
and put them in a freezer.
But when you have a placenta,
there are particular parts of the placenta
you can take the cord blood,
you can take a thing
called Wharton's jelly,
which is this gelatinous
substance made of hyaluronic acid,
where there's particular
concentration of stem cells
you can also isolate.
- We can also isolate
stem cells from adults.
Again, these are stem
cells that have, you know,
gone down their trajectory
from pluripotency
often to multipotency, and so they're not,
you know, they're more aged,
but sort of the earlier we
do this, the better, right?
- Yeah, these stem cells
in adults don't just age
and become dysfunctional, they
can out-compete each other.
They can grow faster.
If you have mutations in
genes like Tet-1, Tet-2, DMTs,
they grow faster and
can actually out-compete
the rest of the immune system.
If you look at hundred year olds,
often they only have one or two
instead of thousands of
types of immune cells,
which is a real problem
if they get pneumonia.
It's often why these elderly people
don't survive in infection.
So what you might want to
do is to bank these HSEs,
hematopoietic stem cells
when you're younger,
so that you can replace your immune system
as you get older.
- However we obtain the stem cells,
researchers are using them
for all kinds of diseases.
They're being used to
regenerate and repair disease
in damaged tissues, in people
with spinal cord injuries,
type one diabetes, Parkinson's disease,
ALS, Alzheimer's, heart disease,
stroke, burns, cancer, arthritis,
and the reason why I'm
like making this big list
is because now thanks to what,
I mean, like really
you've done this to me,
anytime I hear a big list of diseases,
and one singular thing
that can address all of those diseases,
I don't think of those
diseases separately anymore.
I think of aging.
And there's a lot of implications here
for the potential to use stem
cells perhaps to treat aging
and a lot of people
like these other things
we were talking about,
are really excited about
this potential avenue
for anti-aging.
- Well, they do have a lot of potential.
First of all, we can make new organs
using these induced
pluripotent stem cells or IPCs.
And even these autologous
stem cells we're talking about
that you can pull out from
children and from adults,
they can be used to replace
stem cells that get old.
But there's a real fundamental drawback
to using stem cells to live longer.
And that is that they often
don't find their niche,
their resting place.
Even if you inject them into the eye,
often they don't find their home,
and in fact, one of the problems was
when researchers did this
to patients in Florida,
there were three people who became blind
when it wasn't done correctly.
So-
- That coincided with an FDA order
that said, "hey, everybody, slow it down.
Be careful."
- You can get some stem
cell therapies now,
but the majority of them
have been banned for now.
But what is really a problem is that
if you can't get them to the right place,
they're not going to
rejuvenate the whole body.
So what we're looking at now is,
how do you rejuvenate
the existing stem cells
and stop them getting old,
or even reverse the aging
of the stem cells, in situ,
where they exist, and we'll get to that,
but this is the reprogramming
technology that should work,
not just on normal cells,
but even stem cells to make
them young, truly young again.
- All right, and there's been
a lot of research showing
that stem cells can have
a therapeutic effect
in like specific parts of the body,
but when we talk about this
like aging umbrella in general,
there was one study, actually two studies,
a phase one study to phase
two study from researchers
at the University of Miami in 2017
that gave stem cell therapy,
harvested stem cells
from younger donors, gave
them to older frail patients
and small scale, but
it showed improvements
in the distances that
these people could walk,
it lowered the levels of cytokines,
it improved their mental state,
and they had a reported quality
of life improvement as well.
- Yeah, I mean, that's remarkable.
Couple of studies can be reproduced,
but for now what most people are using
the mesenchymal stem
cells for is in joints
when you wear out the joint
and there's not a lot of collagen,
injections of stem cells into those joints
seems to be at least therapeutic
for a short amount of time,
whether or not it's because
the stem cells stay in there
or the secreting exosomes or
other peptides, it's unclear.
- So this is another area
of research then that again,
probably people don't want to
just walk into a clinic tomorrow
and get a stem cell injection.
Because like you said,
the stem cells might not
even know where to go,
but in the future,
this is likely to be part of
people's common anti-aging regimen.
- Well, I'm sure.
I think the future looks like this,
that we can keep our bodies
healthy by eating right,
doing physical exercise,
taking the right medicine
slash supplements,
and when that doesn't
work and things fail,
you can then rebuild the body,
replace cells, put in your organs.
And that way, we'll live
probably many decades
longer than we can currently live.
- And then there's one more
thing that in the future
we may be able to do,
and this leads us to this thing
that you're doing in your lab right now,
you've had quite a few
published studies on
that are pretty darn exciting.
We're talking about
cellular reprogramming.
- Well, this is the big one.
We've been working for many
years on slowing aging,
but we've wanted, how do
you get that to be reversed?
Is there a reset switch in an old cell?
And we think we found it.
We're standing, of
course, on the shoulders
of Shinya Yamanaka who
showed you can reset
the age of a cell back to zero,
but that of course causes cancer,
and if you do that in a
mouse, it'll die within days.
So that's not going to be
a therapy anytime soon.
I don't recommend it.
But what a wonderful
student, Wan Chang Lu did
a few years ago in my lab
was he found a set of genes
that are Yamanaka factors
that were able to reverse
the age of cells and tissues in an animal
and in human cells to a certain point,
going back about 80% of
age, but not to zero.
So that this was a new, safe
approach to reversing the age
of the body without any
negative side effects.
- And he did this is by instead of
using all five Yamanaka
factors, you use three of them.
- Three, and the c-MYC, which is the M,
we definitely don't want
that in there, or LIN28.
These are what are called oncogenic genes,
cancer causing genes.
So we left those out, and
surprisingly those other three,
O, S, and K for short, worked.
Not just in cells in the dish,
but even in the whole animal.
We focused on the eye because
we thought reversing blindness
would be pretty cool and could be a drug,
a very quick drug to develop
relative to the whole body.
And it worked.
Wan Chang sent me a text
of a picture of an eye
where he also regenerated the
optic nerve that was crushed,
and then he went on to
restore vision in mice
that were given glaucoma,
which is pressure in the eye,
and even restored eyesight
to blind old mice.
- Let's slow this down a little bit
and take people through the process,
because if we've gone from like, you know,
Yamanaka factors to
restoring eyesight in mice.
Let's talk about first,
the conditions that
were trying to be fixed
were damaged optic nerve cells.
And you used AAVs, these delivery viruses,
to send the three Yamanaka
factors into the cell.
Once they were there,
what started happening?
- Well, to be clear, our genome
has the Yamanaka genes in it,
but they're normally only turned on
when we're little embryos.
So we had to reintroduce those three genes
with a system where we
could turn them on at will,
and we were using an
antibiotic to turn them on
called doxycycline.
We injected them with
the virus into the eye.
It's a very simple procedure.
In fact, a lot of patients that are blind
get this treatment
already with other drugs.
So it doesn't hurt.
Only takes 10 minutes.
We put into the eye of the mouse.
We damage the eye and asked,
could those reprogrammed
eyes that we reprogrammed
for a month, could they regrow?
And the answer was yes.
- And not only did they regrow,
but these mice that
were effectively blind,
they were blind, you can do little tests
and you can see that
their eyes actually work
like young mice eyes again.
- We put a pressure in
the eye to mimic glaucoma,
which is a major cause of
blindness in the world,
or we just let the mice
age out to one year of age
and they were blind essentially.
And we could tell that they were blind
because we show them
little images that move,
lines actually that
moved from left to right.
And if a mouse can see that,
young mice will move their heads,
it's called the opto-motor response.
- Literally, you can see videos of this.
It's really cute.
They're like watching a tennis match.
- Yeah, we do that too by the way.
We also, of course, we measure
the electrical activity
of those nerves.
We also measure the age
of those nerve cells,
we look at which genes
are switched on and off,
and the conclusion was that
the nerves went back in time,
back to the reset, full reset
to about 80%, their genes,
the gene expression
patterns as we call it,
which is which genes are on and off,
was reset to being young again,
and the mice got their vision back,
as almost as good as they
were when they were young.
- So a lot of people
will hear this and say,
"man, this is really cool.
You can reset blindness in a mouse
or reset vision in a mouse.
Can we do this with other cells?"
- Yeah, it turns out that
it's not just nerve cells
that can be rejuvenated
and sent back in time.
We've done this for skin cells,
we're doing it for muscle cells,
we've done it for other parts of the eye,
and in fact that the shape of the eye
and the structure of the eye,
it doesn't just go back in time,
it actually rebuilds itself
like it's young again.
So we're super optimistic that this may be
a universal mechanism of
age resetting in the body
that can not just be applied
to different mouse tissues,
but also in humans as well.
And we're in the process,
hopefully in a year,
year and a half, of
trying to restore vision
in human patients that
have lost their vision
due to either glaucoma
or genetic diseases.
- So this is happening
because it's accessing
the backup copy of the original
state of the genetic code
that the cells are
building themselves up by?
- Well, the genetic code stays the same,
the epigenetic code, which
is the reader of the DNA,
which we talked about in
episode one, that gets reset.
So those structures of DNA folds
that have gone awry during aging,
this exdifferentiation process
where cells lose their identity,
that gets reset back to youthfulness.
But how that happens, how
do you get a loop of DNA
to go back into a bundle,
and a bundle to go back into a loop?
We have no idea how that works.
We know that there's a backup
copy of not the genome,
but the epigenome, the
structures that read the DNA,
similar to polishing the scratches on a CD
with the analogy we talked
about in episode one,
but how does the cell do that?
How does it reestablish
that original software,
and re-install the software in the cell?
We're only just trying
to figure that out now.
Eventually we will know how this works
and maybe we'll even develop a pill
instead of a gene therapy
that could reset the age,
not just of the eye, but the whole body.
And when that happens,
suddenly it can be a very different world.
But until then we'll work on vision,
and then we'll see where we go from there.
- Well, suffice it to say,
there are several ways that we think
that we can get the human body to do this,
to reset the epigenetic clock.
We can do it through
cellular reprogramming,
it looks like it's possible
to do through exosomes,
and you just mentioned pills.
And it does appear that it's possible
that this is what Metformin
is contributing to,
and some of the other
drugs and supplements
that we talked about
in an earlier episode,
but I mention Metformin
because a lot of people
are going to say, "okay,
all of this stuff is great.
You've told me a bunch of stuff
that probably won't be
accessible to me anytime soon."
There is a treatment regimen
that is being tested out right now
that starts with Metformin,
but a couple of other elements as well.
Let's talk about that.
- Yeah, this is my colleague, Greg Fahy,
Dr. Greg Fahy, and he's been working on
anti-aging or longevity
treatments for awhile,
and he hit upon a triple treatment.
He uses growth hormone,
which is known to raise
blood sugar levels,
we talked about that as a downside,
but then he realized if
he could include DHEA,
a hormone that is depleted during aging,
as well as Metformin, he could mitigate
the negative effects of growth hormone.
And he gave that for 12
months to 10 healthy men
that were aged 51 to
65, and lo and behold,
when he looked at the
biological clock of those men,
they went back two and a half years.
Which may not sound like a
lot, but as I thought about it,
if you could truly reverse your age
every year by one year, that
means you're not going to age.
- All right, something that confuses me
about this combinatory therapy regimen
that Fahey used in this small-scale trial
is that it takes advantage
of human growth hormone,
which earlier in this episode we said
probably not a long-term
anti-aging benefit.
So what was the idea, do
you think, behind using HGH?
- Well, HGH had been shown previously
to reconstitute the thymus.
This is a little organ gland
that's here in your chest
that is important for the immune system.
This is where your T cells,
your immune cells come from,
and growth hormone can stimulate
the regeneration of this
as it degrades over time.
I'm age 50, I probably have what's called
a lot of thymic
degeneration and involution.
It's a vestige of what it used to be.
And growth hormone can stimulate that,
but it comes with side
effects as we mentioned,
not least of which is increase
in insulin insensitivity
or glucose intolerance.
In other words, the cell
doesn't take up the glucose
from the body when you have a
lot of growth hormone around.
So he combined that with
two diabetes therapies,
one is Metformin, which everybody knows,
and Greg also showed
actually in an experiment
that he did on himself that DHEA,
this hormone that some
people take for longevity,
can also control blood glucose levels.
So that combination of
three gave the best effect.
But I should say that measuring
the clock in the blood
doesn't mean the whole
body is being rejuvenated.
That's just one indicator.
So what I'd like to see
Greg and his colleagues do
is to measure aging of other tissues
and measure it using different clocks,
not just the Horvath or epigenetic clock.
- We talked in an earlier episode
about the proteomics clock.
- There's a variety of clocks.
There's glycan age,
which are sugars that
are attached to proteins
that change over time, and
there's one called immuno age.
You measure various changes
in the immune system.
Altogether, these can be
used to get a better picture
of whether Greg's treatment
is truly reversing aging
or just some aspects of it.
- But the really frustrating thing is,
even with these clocks right now,
we don't know what we
don't know, five years,
10 years, 20 years down the line.
So it's a really good indicator
if we can get these clocks to reset,
if we can get these clocks
to lower, like Greg did,
at least in the short term.
In the long-term, do we have
to wait for the longterm?
- Well, it depends.
I know that Greg's research is ongoing
and that I was with him
a couple of months ago,
and he told me that repeated treatments
over more than a year actually reduce age
based on this blood clock, even more so,
and people are going back
by a decade apparently,
so super interesting time.
I would say the jury is still out
whether this is truly reversing aging
or just some aspects of blood aging,
but it's a very interesting
time that we live in
where people are ostensibly
going back in time.
- One of the commonalities, I think,
in almost all of these things
that we've talked about today
is there are these early indications
that something might have effects
and people are jumping over
one another to get to them,
and you know, I mean, some
people are going overseas,
if they can't get it here,
they're finding doctors
willing to do this,
they're finding suppliers
from wherever on the internet they can,
and it's understandable, right?
Because people are suddenly
awakened to this idea
that aging may not be something
that we have to tolerate in the long-term.
So they're eager, but there's still work
that needs to be done.
- There is.
But what I think is really exciting
is we wrote our book,
"Lifespan" in 2018, '19,
and we envisage a future where people
could turn their clock
back and be rejuvenated.
It's only been a couple
of years since then,
and there's been a huge
advance in the ability
to reprogram the body, to measure it.
These tests are now
available to the public
to measure biological age
from blood and from spit.
We're in an age where I would
say it's hard to even predict
where we'll be in five,
especially in 10 years from now.
- But if you're frustrated,
if you're really overeager,
there are things I think
this needs to be said.
Like you can take steps right now.
You don't have to necessarily
be taking peptides
and exosomes and you don't
have to hunt down Greg and say,
"you know, like give me
this combinatory therapy!"
Just slowing down the
biological clock right now,
doing the things that we talked about
in the first few episodes,
is going to buy you that
time for these therapies
to mature to the place where
we know that they're safe,
we know what they're going to do.
- Right.
- So stay young, stay alive,
because the future looks bright
just with the current pace of medicine
and medical technologies,
if you live an extra year,
you get another three months of life.
We could easily approach a
time where every year you live,
you get another year of life.
And that's when the world
becomes super interesting.
- What are we talking about next episode?
- We are talking about
aging on the outside.
So we've talked a lot about
how to keep your insides young.
Next episode, we can talk
about your skin, your hair,
your nails, how to keep
those looking good,
and it's not just superficial.
It's really important.
It's actually been shown
that if you look younger
on the outside, you probably
young on the inside too.
So stay tuned for that.
If you're enjoying this podcast
and would like to support us,
please subscribe on YouTube,
Apple podcasts, and Spotify.
On Apple, you have the opportunity
to leave us up to a five star review.
Also check out the
sponsors that we mentioned
at the start of the episode.
That's probably the best
way to support the show.
We also have a Patreon account.
That's patreon.com/davidsinclair.
There you can support the
show at any level you'd like.
Thanks again for joining
us on this episode
of the Lifespan podcast.